[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro de six ans par les sports ce talk
et pour les passionnés de sport local et
de sport évinois aujourd'hui au
programme comme toujours une dose de
bonne humeur des analyses sportives et
surtout des coups de gueule et des à
débat nos chroniqueurs sont avec nous en
plateau ou via écran interposé pour
s'exprimer sur cette actualité sportive
revinoise à présentation on commence
tout de suite par notre italiana lover
celui qui fait chavirer les coeurs des
supporters et des supportrices de cette
émission il connaît tout sur tout sa
clause libératoire vient de passer le
milliard d'euros depuis son excellente
performance lors de la dernière émission
gregory kane aller de tv 78 est avec
nous bonjour michael bonjour à tous et
en irak en augmentant à puisque le
mercato va bientôt s'ouvrir un milliard
un milliard cinq peut-être 2 milliards
c'est vrai on peut pas trop en dire
alors on continue les présentations
musique c'est l'un des pères fondateurs
de sault talk il est également passionné
de cyclisme sur piste et de cyclisme en
général mais dernièrement il s'est
découvert une nouvelle passion pour la
voile le capitaine yann jarrier est avec
nous pendant une heure quand allez-vous
me yaël ça va très très bien avec ce
bonne chaleur naquit qui donne du baume
au coeur
voilà oui c'est la dernière émission de
l'année en vous teniez à être ici un oui
justement on n'a pas eu beaucoup ça a
été une année quand même très compliqué
donc oui c'est vrai que c'est quand même
bien sympa d'être d'être là sur sur la
dernière en est on est bien d'accord et
et puis vivement l'année prochaine et
une année qui sera complète et qu'il
sera plein et qui sera une année normale
on l'espère alors on continue par l'un
des symboles de cette émission musique
c'est un rugbyman d'exception qui nous
vient tout droit de versailles et manie
la langue de molière comme personne et
ça lui permet souvent de remporter à des
duels de gladiateurs pierre chevalier du
rugby-club de versailles est avec nous
comment allez-vous gladiateurs salue les
élèves écoutent forme et bonheur à tous
pour cette dernière émission vianney de
la saison un peu comme yann je suis
content de pouvoir un peu tourner la
page est née une saison pleine et
entière la saison prochaine il ravi de
terminer avec tout et aujourd'hui alors
lui aussi est une figure un mythe de
cette émission musique c'est également
rugbyman il n'a pas sa langue dans sa
poche il adore plaqués sept adversaires
le long de la ligne de touche
mesdames et messieurs jaunisse ex-coach
de plaisir est avec lui bonjour à tous
et à toutes vos jours mickaël quand
allez-vous plateforme toujours plein de
formes pour la dernière de l'émission
et puis avait vivement le retour sur le
plateau si c'est peu plus j'adore on
l'espère au mois de septembre c'est sur
cette année ça a été compliqué mais on
l'espère pour le mois de septembre
croisons les doigts alors on va terminer
par une petite nouvelle musique c'est sa
troisième titularisation dans cette
émission c'est une trappistes elle a 22
ans elle fait du golf au niveau amateur
depuis environ six ans elle adore taper
la balle blanche dans les golfs zibi
noah c'est également une blogueuse est
une influence sur le golf et féminin
manyan oksana est avec nous pendant une
heure à tous
je suis ravi de vous retrouver
aujourd'hui attendez-vous à daegu
ça va très bien alors pour cette
dernière qu'est ce que vous nous avez
réservé rigole on va voir on en parlera
dans cette émission alors un mot de boxe
on va tout d'abord parlé de boxe pour
commencer elle ira aux jeux olympiques
cet été m'a y va hamadouche licencié au
boxing club de saint quentin en yvelines
avec la team farrugia a gagné son ticket
à pour tokyo dans le grand dôme de
villebon sur yvette la sportif de 31 ans
a battu la hongroise qatar a pris bof ce
qui au point repêchage des moins de 60
kg à l'occasion du tournoi de
qualification olympique la
professionnelle participera donc à ses
premiers jeux olympiques à sera la seule
femme
parmi les cinq qualifiés français sur
ces jeux au niveau de la boxe un avis
tout simplement sur cette qualification
grégory ou subir un petit peu le dossier
depuis plusieurs semaines on suit le
dossier bien évidemment puisqu'elle est
aussi candidate pour être porte drapeau
de la délégation française aux jo je
pense que cette victoire en tout cas
cette qualification il ya une victoire
effectivement contre une hongroise je ne
me risquerai pas à prononcer non vous
l'avez fait très bien michael jusqu'ici
voilà donc ça montre une grande force de
caractère à mon sens puisque on l'a su
après ce tournoi de qualification
olympique maiva hamadouche a subi deux
grosses opérations en bas au cours du
printemps et dont une voilà qui a été
très très difficile elle aurait même pu
perdre son bras en tout cas les mots
qu'elle avait donnée au journal l'équipe
elle est revenue le 15 mai elle a remis
les gants seulement le 15 mai elles
étaient alignés sur ce tournoi de
qualification olympique où ça n'a pas
été facile a fait une victoire d'emblée
elle perd sur le deuxième match elle est
obligée d'aller jouer sa qualification
repêchage donc le fait qu'elle n'avait
que quinze jours de préparation moi à
mon sens ça montre une grande force de
caractère dont bravo à elle c'est une
qualification pour les jo qui est
amplement méritée jean qu'est ce que
vous en pensez vous la connaissez un
mile à un oui oui mais je suis content
tabouret la selle le mérite énormément
parce que c'est une bosseuse c'est
vraiment une bosseuse avec un mental de
folie et non je suis très très très très
content tabourel on a eu peur quand même
un s'était pas fait un voeu au péage
s'était pas sûr et certain non plus un
kalaï oui c'est ça avec avec un arbitre
qui a penché plutôt du côté de
l'adversaire mais ça aurait pu très bien
pour chez de son côté mais c'est la loi
du sport
les arbitres sont indispensables pour le
sport magnifique qu'est ce que vous en
pensez vous sélectionné c'est la seule
femme française qui va représenter la
boxe effectivement 5 4
et elle arrive derrière ce qu'on nous
entende et très très bien mais très très
bien c'est juste michael gregory qui a
été un peu loin longtemps longtemps très
loin n'ont pas cessé super moi j'ai très
très bien qu'elle puisse qu'elle puisse
être qualifié surtout que parle de
mémoire les résultats des bourses heures
français à rio avait été quand même très
très bon je crois qu'il y en avait qu'un
seul qui étaient revenus sans médaille
donc ça peut lui laisser entrevoir une
belle une belle continuité une belle
suite dans dans son parcours olympique
parce que c'est toujours bien de
participer aux jo mais mais c'est quand
même mieux de revenir avec une médaille
et c'est mieux pour le tableau des
médailles français donc
donc c'est tout ce qu'on va pouvoir lui
souhaiter mais c'est déjà du coup on
peut se dire que sa part sur des notes
positives parce que les critères de
sélection français permettent d'accéder
à des beaux résultats par la cei bien
sûr vallier mais je le dis en complément
de ce que disait de ce que disait long
sur le côté bosseur ce que je trouve
absolument le chant c'est que ce sport
qu'on appelle un noble sport j'allais
dire commence mais continue d'être
maître aussi pratique pas que les femmes
et c'est je pense que dans lequel maïva
s'est en plus fait avec avec un mental
qui va au delà de tous les clichés avec
une abnégation a une chance de caractère
qui force le respect justement il suffit
dans des conditions de qualification
comme elle a connu et d'avoir d'avoir
une représentante éventuellement une
porte drapeau et par délégation
française
c'est un jeu qu'on cherche à toutes ces
femmes qui sont sa ligne dans des tons
plutôt dans les sports on va dire que
dans 10 sport d'hommes et qui c'est qui
tireront leur épingle du jeu et c'est
vraiment c'est vraiment un coup de
chapeau ennuis à lui a dit oui justement
est ce qu'elle doit être porte drapeau
maintenant on sait que le porte drapeau
parce qu'il ya deux porte drapeaux 1
cette année il ya un porte drapeau homme
et un drap porte drapeau femmes
elle sera du coup peut-être porte
drapeau à femmes du coup pour pour c'est
pour ces jeux olympiques
est ce que oui ou non reste qu'elle peut
être porte drapeau grégory c'est
possible parce que ça a été dit c'est
déjà la seule représentante féminine de
son sport la boxe la boxe qui a réussi
effectivement aux français en 2016 et
moi j'ai envie de vous dire le porte
drapeau c'est aussi à quelques quelqu'un
de l'exemplarité voilà c'est un exemple
pour la délégation française y aura un
porte drapeau homme un porte drapeau
femmes et on sait que maiva hamadouche
on en a parlé avec jean la dernière fois
qu'ils qui la connaît bien voilà c'est
une première mais son double parcours
d'athlète et aussi de police hier
puisque les très engagé également dans
cette carrière là à mon sens mériterait
d'être mise en avant avec ce rôle de
porte drapeau donc elle le mérite
amplement
il fallait qu'elle soit aux jo puisque
ce n'était pas sûr qu'elle soit audio
maintenant c'est le cas et donc on a on
est en attente
on va dire avec impatience de voir si
c'est elle qui va être porte drapeau
féminin pour cette délégation française
et on aura la réponse dans les prochains
jours pierre chevallier je crois vous
voulez rajouter quelque chose oui le
choix de mes choix du ou des porte
drapeaux et un choix qui est connotée
comment qu'il n'y ait pas une politique
ni et au delà du symbole et c'est vrai
que c'est dans les critères de choix je
pense que cette notion d'exemplarité
côté greg et de deux signatures des
valeurs sportives des valeurs de
l'olympisme sont passés importante
là il pourrait elle pourrait lui
proposer proposé un visage
justement pour ces valeurs sont les
écorchés plus ce que défend la
délégation française
il ya du jarrier rapidement porte
drapeau oui ou non pour maiva hamadouche
très rapidement je vais faire un petit
tour de table
j'ai pas changé de discours parce que je
disais dernière fois le problème c'est
qu'aujourd'hui elle manque un petit peu
de notoriété et dans le monde du dans le
monde m dans le monde des médias et dans
le monde rappelait pas des médias mais
dans le monde et des sportifs moi je la
connaissais pas du tout avant qu'on en
parle en tant que porte drapeau je me
suis renseigné en effet elle le mérite
maintenant je pense que damas et manque
un peu de visibilité et pour moi la
judokate qui en plus vient de gagner un
cinquième titre de championne du monde
voilà encore un nom un peu compliqué
mais voilà pour moi je pense que c'est
elle qui risque de me couper l'herbe
sous le pied parce que voilà c'est un
très très beau parcours sportif et et
elle le mérite aussi oscille amplement
mais voilà il y aura qu'un seul porte
drapeau et et c'est un problème d'
élections et donc
donc voila c il n'y a qu'un seul gagnant
voilà ils sont plusieurs à plusieurs en
ligne deux sur la ligne de départ mais
il y aurait quatre sets gagnants et pour
moi ouais la judokate et je pense
favorite manil après je passe la parole
à agent manila qu'elles soient tous les
sportifs et encore plus ce succès la
seule fameux killer
heureusement la grippe ce et au sida
les mois je pense qu'elle peut percer le
fait qu'elle en bon de bien performer le
joug de la compétition et du coup c'est
à ce moment là
en plus elle est encore jeune
la boxe à la 31 ans le précise à la
gagne 22 combats sur 23 chez les
professionnels elle a encore du temps on
sait que les boxeurs ça peut combattre
jusqu'à 45 ans des x 50 ans pour mike
tyson pourquoi pas
genre qu'est ce que vous en pensez très
rapidement très rapidement mais bon vous
savez pertinemment proférées sur un
verre mais il va bien sûr mais 4 2 4 et
yann disait bon qu'elle a pas de
lisibilité par rapport à une clarisse je
préfère dire son prénom de son bord au
niveau du judo avec ses sept titres
mondiaux mais quelques mois qu'avec son
cinquième titre mondial a même pas parlé
à la télévision des années dans les
différents magazines sportifs
la très très peu vu donc bon je pense
que l'on peut nativité au niveau du
public n'est pas n'est pas aussi le plus
jeune cette affaire donc qu'une petite
préférable pour moi il va à l'oreille
très rapidement prendre en question en
asie pour rebondir sur ce que disait
yann c'est que le dernier porte drapeau
français c'est un judoka set était
d'irina aux jo de rio en 2016 donc
pourquoi pas voir aussi un autre sport
mise en avant
et peut-être que justement on ne
choisira pas de mettre forcément le judo
en avant pour cette délégation française
alors nous allons maintenant passer au
programme de l'émission aujourd'hui nous
allons parler des autres sportifs
yvelinois qui participeront aux jeux
olympiques le département des yvelines
va-t-il porter cette équipe de france au
sommet coup de projecteur également sur
le cavalier international victor
lévesque il a décidé de déménager à
maisons-laffitte pour continuer sa
progression
mais avant de développer ces thèmes on
va parler à football
[Musique]
on va donc parler football les yvelinois
ont vibré en regardant le premier match
de l'équipe de france à l'euro dans ce
bar de saint-germain-en-laye
les supporters ont encouragé les bleus
pendant toute la partie ce mardi 15 juin
contre l'allemagne
et pour une fois à la fin ce sont les
français qui l'ont emporté à 0 face à
leurs voisins et forcément les
supporters étaient très heureux on les
écoute
l'équipe de france est aussi l'allemagne
très gros match mais vive la france
impeccable il continue comme ça on va on
va y aller en droit dedans
[Applaudissements]
kohler
des images qui font plaisir un pierre
chevallier je vous ai vu sourire
évidemment que ça fait plaisir c'est
après une après tellement de deux
périodes de frustration de 18 mois sans
public sont connaître les stades et là
on a un euro 2020 ce choix heureusement
qu'il se joue on commence à ouvrir puis
qui commence à revivre normalement et on
commence tout de suite par une grosse
affiche un france-allemagne qui on a
connu d historique de 82 en passant
outre aux compétitions internationales
sur vous ça fait plaisir de voir tout le
monde de voir tous vibré je sois chez
soi chez soi demandé dans des bars dans
des restos et c'est qui qui trop mais je
m'en serais pas tout tout de suite un
convive nos favoris en tout cas une
équipe qui provient pas de chance durant
comme ça mais avec un but de raccroc
amap et aurait repris geipan derrière sa
chance alors avec cette victoire la
france est 2e de son groupe f derrière
le portugal qui a gagné 3 0 l'équipe de
france affrontera ce samedi 19 juin la
hongrie pour se qualifier
la question sur cette thématique la
france est elle définitivement la grande
favorite de l'euro
oui ou non voter oui pour vous grégory
non pour vous gens vous êtes partagés
pierre partage également pour yann
manila vous êtes non alors on fait on
fait un petit duel entre vous jean et
grégory saint jean vous commencez oui
moi j'ai j'ai mis le pousse à l'envers
mais je voulais pas du tout l'effet sais
pas je ne voulais pas dire de nom
on est sur le point catégorie r duet là
et grégory indique que tout de suite
ouais vous l'affrontez grégory tout à
fait non je disais que ces voix là j'ai
bord mamba a considéré que je dis non
alors c'est prometteur certes maintenant
c'est le premier match et puis on sait
pertinemment qu'une phrase on n'est
jamais aussi mauvais leucate donné
favori donc là la compétition débute
laissons les sauces cette équipe de
phrasé qui m'a l'air très semaine qui a
calé à avoir un jeu assez assez posé
avec des éléments de grande qualité ça
tout le monde le dit on n'arrête pas de
le répéter sur le sépare c'est votre
saut est aveugle mais parce que l'on
rabâche assez mêlé sol et les soldes et
travailler laissant des traces qu'il
laisse on les gagne et en toute sérénité
parce que le fait de commencer à dire
même observé commencé d'ailleurs l'euro
que c'étaient les grands favoris et que
même s'était déjà fait qu'on l'avait
gagnée on sait qu'un vase ça nous
réussit pas ce genre de choses
il ya eu un bon match hier encore une
fois avec une grande sérénité
le contre contre l'équipe d'allemagne
qui quand même pas la dernière venue
donc c'est on va dire qu'on peut être
optimiste mais ne vendent pas là pour la
peau de l'ours avant de l'avoir tué et
jeté grigori oui bien sûr c'est la
grande favorite quand on regarde
l'effectif de l'équipe de france à
chaque ligne à les tops mondiaux à
chaque fois alors que dire du mieux
terrain avec pogba avec kant et que dire
de l'attaqué avec ce trio griezmann
benzema bape et hier qui a été encore
très virevoltant un moment donné qui met
une grosse vitesse à à mathieu mail ci
est d'ailleurs peut-être penalty sur sur
l'occasion il était parti avec trois
mètres de retard et il arrive quand même
en avance sur sur la course après ça ne
veut pas dire grande favorite ça ne veut
pas dire forcément qu il va remporter
l'euro on a vu dans des compétitions
précédentes par exemple le portugal si
on prend l'équipe portugaise sur l'euro
les portugais n'était pas annoncés
favoris ils ont fait une compétition
même sans remporter il me semble un
match dans l'est dans les 90 minutes
et au final ils s'imposent face à la
france en finale ils n'étaient pas
donnés favoris et pourtant ils ont
rapporté 7 euros donc ça veut pas dire
oui à les favorites ça veut pas dire
forcément qu il va remporter 7 euros
maintenant le sentiment que j'ai eu moi
sur ce match c'est pas l'équipe qui m'a
le plus impressionné sur ce premier tour
mais c'est l'équipe en tout cas qui est
la plus sereine ça c'est vrai je suis
d'accord avec ce qui a été dit on a le
sentiment quand même que cette équipe de
france a peu joué pendant trois heures
sans encaisser de but c'est le sentiment
vraiment que moi j'ai eu hier parce
qu'elle a laissé le jeu à l'allemagne si
on regarde les chiffres du match
l'allemagne a eu 59 % de possession de
balle à 10 tirs dont 6 cadrés pour les
allemands seulement quatre côtés côté
français donc elle a laissé le jeu aux
allemands c'est clairement pas une
équipe de france qui va forcément avoir
le jeu à son compte
maintenant quand elle a le ballon elle
élit talent elle sait placer des
attaques très bien très précise et donc
c'est plutôt ça moi que je retiens c'est
une équipe de france sereine et qui en
plus lankaise pas de but on va voir si
elle va au bout de cette compétition
mais en général les équipes qui
défensivement sont très solides vont au
bout des compétitions manila qui vous a
convaincu je donnerais à paroles aliens
dujarrier ensuite pourquoi j'ai voté non
en fait je voulais mettre mitigé parce
que c'est vraiment à moi convaincu alors
je pense que c'est chaud c'est plus
c'est plus gens pourquoi alors du coup
la savine le mât jeunes comme parrain du
pont le gagner
comment sait on a gagné des matches nous
ont vraiment pas ce pur pour manier la
ja dujarrier je l'aurais à paroles
ensuite à pierre je sais que vous êtes
vous voulez tous cas agir sur la
question il ya du marié on a fait le
match qu'il fallait faire contre les
allemands il faut savoir que les
allemands jouer quand même à domicile
en plus on a quand même fait un match à
12 13 contre 11
parce que il avait public et en plus ils
avaient leurs vitres avec eux
je pense qu'on a vraiment fait le match
qu'il fallait et contre une contre une
équipe qu'ils avaient la capacité de
prendre le jeu en main voilà on a montré
que défensivement on était on est et on
était là on était rien à faire pour
pouvoir passer cette défense ce sera
complètement différent contre des
équipes où l'équipe de france devra
prendre devra prendre le jeu à son
compte et est la grande force de cette
équipe de france et qu'elle est capable
de prendre justement le jeu à son compte
contrairement à l'équipe de 2018 qui
part dont deux ont été les championnes
en 2020 c'est ça les années passent si
vite
yann jorrion léon et perd je veux être
pas voilà quand on est des champions du
monde la veine équipe qui était très
forte défensive et qui ne jouait que en
contre attaque
c'était un petit peu ce qui s'est passé
hier mais ce ne sera pas le cas sur tous
les matches il va y avoir des matches où
la france sera capable de prendre de
prendre le jeu à son compte et karim
benzema fera une forêt d'une grosse
différence à ce moment là sur les sur
les mouvements sur les mouvements et
apportera le plus qui manquait qui
manquait il ya il l'avait dernière
compétition on a un milieu de terrain
qui est juste énorme
voilà moi je pense que c'était la
meilleure manière de commencer cet euro
voilà de gagner sereinement
c'est vraiment le mot qui restent qui
reste quand on regarde ce match serein
maintenant on a encore beaucoup pas à
prouver beaucoup pas montré je pense que
le match de samedi devrait être là pour
confirmer ce qui s'est passé sur sur le
match d'hier
et après ça va ça va dérouler de toute
façon une chose est sûre c'est que
toutes les équipes nous redoute sas et
c'est la raison pour laquelle on peut
dire que la france est favorite de
l'euro c'est que en effet tous les tous
les entraîneurs des équipes adverses ne
veulent pas de vous rencontrer tout
simplement
donc on est obligé de partager la parole
ariane je sais que vous êtes passionné
je retiens la sérénité et la crainte
qu'inspire je retiens une action
notamment avec les pieds
france au delà de la sérénité un merci
l'inversé le cours du jeu il ya prendre
le match à son compte et surtout à tuer
le match sur le but refusé à karim
benzema avec la récup sur toute la
rencontre
il fait jouer après ont eu 2 mb et et
benzema et qui se trouvent facilement
les tricheurs mais avec en plus un
altruisme de belles truites le dmp comme
le but est refusé pour cette action ça
montre à quel point l'équipe de france
et au delà de cette sérénité capable
capable de prendre le jeu à son compte
et de tuer un match en une action et ça
pour le coup c'est extrêmement
prometteur
laissons-leur un statut d'outsider et
puis depuis un an ou deux certes son
champion du monde en titre mais un
statut d'outsider pour l'instant un peu
caché ça va être de moins en moins parce
que le cheikh a donné le premier match
jusqu'au jusqu'en france portugal
là vraiment c'est sur le potentiel tout
simplement qui sera l'adversaire le
principal adversaire des bleus du coup
sur 7 sur 7 euros grégory si on si on
s'en réfère aux premiers matches qu'on a
vu on a vu une belgique très solide qui
a fait un match vraiment plein à face à
la russie avec un romelu lukaku
l'attaquant belle qui est vraiment avec
un doublé de lukaku qui d'ailleurs avait
fait un beau message à eric sehn son
coéquipier à l'inter qui est aussi l'une
des images malheureuse de ses premiers
matches et l'autre équipe moi qui m'a
qui m'a pas mal plus c'est l'angleterre
dans la solidité aussi face à cette
croix si on sait que c'est un match
difficile pour les anglais qui a été
remportée 1 but à 0 par l'angleterre
avec un but de rim sterling mais
l'angleterre moi ça me paraît pas mal ça
me paraît pas mal aussi pour pour
pouvoir on va dire déstabiliser un peu
cette équipe française
j'attends de voir un peu plus du
portugal le portugal hier qui est ok
s'est imposé 3 buts à 0 à l'arrière
alors on enregistre cette émission ce
qu'on l'enregistré
en ce mercredi 16 juin mais ils ont
marqué les buts dans les dix dernières
minutes ça s'est décanté sur sur la fin
sur la fin de la rencontre avec un
cristiano ronaldo qui en plus est devenu
le meilleur buteur de l'histoire de
l'euro avec 11 buts donc pour le moment
oui les deux équipes moi qui me que je
retiens sur ce premier tour
c'est la belgique c'est l'angleterre est
allé pour le coeur je place aussi
l'italie qui a fait aussi une belle
entrée en matière dans cet euro 3 0
contre la turquie 1 somptueuse victoire
de l'italie si y'a déjà riez il ya des
fois vaut un favori autre que la france
je sais pas rapidement
moi vous poser la question à moins
favori autre que la france ne s'est même
pas possible que je vous donne un autre
nom je ne peux pas c'est pas dans mes
gènes c'est pas dans la bresse sanguin
je suis français c'est tout c'est comme
ça il n'y a pas d'autre possibilité
je ne peux pas donner un autre pays
c'est pas assez par le hamas à la parole
à jean alors du coup genre mais en
belgique pour moi la belgique gens y ont
fait forte impression
manila rapidement il en fait la france
mais que la france pour vous aussi
et pierre rapidement france belgique
angleterre j'arrivais même le même car
c'est que greg et jean alors je précise
quand même que cette victoire est un peu
grâce à la préparation de l'équipe de
france la préparation qui s'est passé à
clairefontaine dans les yvelines
est-ce que ça a joué à grégory non mais
on sait noir c'est le lien de l'équipe
de france avec les ivy non je ne sais
pas si ça a joué c'est vrai que
clairefontaine où vous il y avait déjà
été michael en tout cas c'est des
installations vraiment de très haute
qualité
il ya c'est un petit écrin dans les
yvelines à l'abri on va dire à des
médias même si les médias peuvent y
rentrer mais c'est on sait
clairefontaine ça a été le berceau des
gros succès des bleus le succès des
bleus en 98 tout ils ont totalement
préparé cette coupe du monde à domicile
à clairefontaine
ça a failli être le cas pour l'euro 2016
et malheureusement il ya eu cette
défaite face au portugal en finale et
bien sûr va la coupe du monde 2018 même
si elle sait jouer en russie
la préparation s'est faite à
clairefontaine je pense que c'est un
paramètre quand même qu'il faut prendre
en compte ce cette ville de
clairefontaine ce village même qui
al'avantage d'être à proximité paris
mais à s'éloigner pour éviter on va dire
la foule même si elle s'y pressent pour
les entraînements de l'équipe de france
alors on souhaite évidemment bon courage
aux français pour la suite de leur
parcours et surtout une victoire contre
la hongrie qui permettrait sûrement à
l'équipe de france de se qualifier pour
ces huitièmes de finale de l'euro on va
maintenant par les golfs antoine ros
nord
pas démérité lors du mémorial tournament
début juin le golfeur du racing club de
france à la boulie termine à une très
belle 18e place du prestigieux tournoi
américain il a bouclé son dernier tour
en plus de au dessus du par mais il peut
nourrir quelques regrets il a réalisé un
boguey au trou numéro deux et un
quadruple au numéro trois les vinoy
termine finalement au même niveau que
les cadors du circuit comme brian 200
veaux rory mcilroy
le tournoi a lui été remporté par
l'américain patrick cantlay antoine
rosner devrait maintenant revenir en
europe pour la suite de sa saison la
question sur ce thème
après deux quêtes manqué sur ses
premiers tournois aux états unis au
byron nelson et à lui à speed gier la
carrière américaine d'antoine runner est
elle définitivement lancée oui ou non
après cette belle 18e place dubitatif
pour vous rien dit j'ai rayé oui bon ton
les plus ou moins d'accord manila qu'est
ce que vous en pensez vous êtes un peu
notre spécialiste golf avec dire je
pense que j'ai pas mal d'amis qui ont
dit à jouer avec eux antoine y je pense
que j'y joue très très bien
il a dix d'en être loin et obéissez
célérité après c'est à voir parce qu'ils
vont elles pas beaucoup de français sur
les circuits américains et al rai
tempéré dans également wii n'a pas
beaucoup mais dans le cas c'est vraiment
c'est moi c'est vraiment avoir avoir
personnellement pierre chevallier
ce qu'il faut retenir pour antoine c'est
que c'est que malgré le fait qu'il soit
né dans une famille de golfeurs
historique de guerre cf la ville se
destiner paraître joueurs amateurs et
professionnels chez les cons sport avant
avant de s'y mettre et que après que la
génétique et le celta familial ainsi si
j'ai bien compris chez antoine ros
knuble cher alors on y mange bien des
coupables
donc je travaillais en dessous il ya des
frais il ya les frères que ce qui change
et par aig qui joue du tort au golf mais
c'est ce qu'il faut retenir sa fraîcheur
par rapport à boukari à 9 heures et un
talent naturel amener la balle
expérience universitaire ça va jouer ça
va jouer dans la découverte du circuit
américain
et puis là il envie de jouer mais pas
encore on n'est pas encore trop perverti
par quoi que ce soit par des gains ou
par des entraînements au parvis des
saisons difficiles et et c'est un
certain temps moins turbulent c'est
vraiment un joueur de hull et la nappe
assidûment vraiment une jeune nico tu
vas y corps à côté du corps perez sur le
circuit américain et de toutes choses
qui sont souvent ils se sont essayés eu
un temps un temps madame mais il sent
qu'il faut retenir que assez vite malgré
des deux clubs le pays que vous avez
vous avez appelé en fin d'année dernière
il a une femme et deux points assez
probants des notamment de champion des
matchs plaît déjà en se frottant aux
meilleurs comme celle de chandelle donc
on a là aussi si on n'a pas souvent il
faut laisser le temps à ses joueurs de
maturer performer non pas qu'on vite
dépendra pas du flicage champions mais
en toi a le potentiel et il est bien
entouré
mais les envies des alentours est au
pouvoir l'oryx vous en pensez les 64e
joueur mondial actuellement deuxième
meilleur français qu'est ce que vous en
pensez tout simplement est-ce que ça y
est c'est lancé il pourra il pourra
s'inscrire sur la durée sur le circuit
américain
je le pense j'en suis convaincu et
d'autant que la dernière fois sur sur ce
plateau lorsqu'on a parlé d' antoine ros
nerfs on parle effectivement de ses
débuts peut être un peu raté sur sur le
circuit américain finalement on voit
qu'il a su déjà se relever c'est mes
premières expériences sur ce circuit
américain
pierre parler de ses deux victoires de
l'année dernière donc il poursuit
tranquillement sa carrière je pense que
on l'a peut-être mis un peu trop de
pression après sa victoire contre
brayson de chambre qui avait fait grand
bruit lors des championnats du monde de
match play
donc voilà c'est une suite logique de sa
carrière je pense que c'est un une bonne
lancée pour pour débuter sur le circuit
américain là il va revenir sur le
circuit européen qui connaît très bien
donc on en attend de voir ce qui va se
passer par la suite
jean paul encore la parole le tour le
circuit américain c'est ultra dur c'est
ce qui se fait de mieux sur la planète
golf
donc là déjà il existe depuis l'année
dernière et où aussi champion européen
il a fait des résultats probants un
petit peu mature et pareil pour ça mais
la marche est haute
il figure déjà dans l'escalier il a
l'air d'avoir le niveau 1 gens on est
d'accord
oui oui bah je crois que là tout a été
quasiment 10 sur ce joueur
et c'est vrai que on parle souvent de
certaines défaites valent des victoires
et je pense que la somme qu'a le fle il
a su se remettre en question après son
mauvais départ sur le circuit américain
et saïd a su se remettre en question
c'est aussi la preuve d'un grand joueur
avec un gros mental pour justement ne
pas baisser les bras et tu revenir
revenir au plus haut niveau comme il
était temps de le faire et puis il va à
mon avis il est bien parti il est bien
parti il a tout pour lui
je peux redire tout ce qui a été dit par
mes collègues mais voilà il a tout pour
lui et on ne peut être qu'optimiste à
son égard est ce que vous voulez
rajouter quelque chose ou on passe au à
thématique suivante
non on passe à la thématique suivante on
suivrait évidemment avec attention les
performances d'antoine runner dans les
prochaines semaines on va continuer on
va parler
équitation victor lévesque le cavalier
international de concours complet se
sont déjà chez lui à maisons-laffitte
cette ville mois pure souche a quitté la
boissière école près de rambouillet pour
déménager avec sept de ses chevaux une
décision mûrement réfléchie qui
correspond à ses ambitions il celui de
livres à notre micro
il y avait un aspect géographique
puisque je suis sur la fin de mes études
à sciences po voilages intègre un master
marketing et sociétés s'étaient
importante pour moi pour terminer les
deux ans qui me reste de me rapprocher
un peu de paris y avait aussi la
nécessité de voilà me recentrer un peu
plus sur mes chevaux de compétition j'ai
amené que mes jeux faut vraiment de haut
niveau à maisons-laffitte c'était aussi
un choix personnel
voilà je partage cette passion et ce
sport avec ma copine et puis voilà
c'était je pense important et
intéressant de nous entraîner ensemble
avec cette installation le cavalier de
22 ans espère également trouver un cadre
de vie propice à la pratique de
l'équitation tous les jours victor
l'évêque va s'entraîner dans cette ville
baptisée la cité du cheval en raison de
son importante activité équestre et de
son hippodrome la question at il fait le
bon choix selon vous pour aller aux jeux
olympiques de 2024 oui ou non
oui oui oui ton et tout le monde est ok
il ya dujarrier qu'est ce que vous en
pensez vous qui êtes un grand cavalier
s'est enfin voilà quelqu'un qui épie
star et qui me dit je vais aller
m'entraîner sur le vélodrome 2 2 auxerre
qui est un vélodrome extérieur je suis
désolé quand on veut avoir les meilleurs
résultats on doit se rapprocher des
meilleures installations
donc voilà en effet il était dans les
unités dans les yvelines
maïs et julie là il a eu besoin de
bouger pour plein de raisons qui ont
l'air d'être des raisons en plus tout à
fait louable et réfléchi
il ya un moment où dans la carrière d'un
sportif et de matériel un champion il
faut faire des choix et il les a faits
il va les assumer il va aller et puis de
toute façon ça va bien se passer
derrière
donc pour moi il n'ya pas deux il n'y a
pas de dégâts pas de souci il faut il
faut le faire il faut le faire au bon
moment ben oui là il lui reste trois ans
avant avant paris 2024 donc donc c'est
parfait c'est bon timing
c on doit être meilleur au meilleur
endroit où meilleur moment pour pouvoir
être prêt pour pour les bonnes compte
pour les bonnes compétition manuela
qu'est ce que vous en pensez si vous
êtes d'accord à cannes ça donc c'est un
champion comme s'ils avaient tort c'est
comme c'est un champion je pense que
aller avec mon avis ça va les changer
dalé être avant était à saint nom la
bretèche et un autre à la boissière
l'école en fait c'est à la boissière
l'école donc près de rambouillet il
était la répu toujours on peut le dire
et il arrivait du coi à maisons-laffitte
depuis un mois mois et demi environ
quitte à des belles installations il
pourra bien travaillé son cheval pour
atteindre des performances pour aller
chez gérard chevallier
ce qu'il faut noter c'est laisser le
choix aux choix réfléchi de la tête de
la tête et du sport et du physique
atterri memories étude nous aussi donc
il allait taper des gens aient le choix
maison à mon avis à l'assemblée flashy
et c'est la seule issue parce que des
installations spécifiques équestre il
aurait tué les détachants tine et vous
monsieur arrêtez sont arrêtés aussi les
mentions ce qu il ne voulait se
rapprocher de paris pour avoir pourquoi
rld et d'utile à la guerre séculaire à
l'entraînement dans tous mes ennuis
d'être une ville je pense apporte-t-elle
mais sérénité pour des champions qui se
compare donc extrêmement bons choix
judicieux et on espère gagnant pour pour
dominique y aurait plus de chevaux que
d'habitants selon la légende genre
qu'est ce que vous en pensez
ebr être bien 8e très belles maisons
laffitte
s'il est vraiment bon est ce qu'il a et
du autres prochaine qualité reflex et je
ne sais pas il n'est pas dit non mais
pékin s'est très bien très très bien et
très bien je rejouais pierre dans son
analyse
c'est un garçon qui non seulement est
brillante dans sa discipline mais qui à
mon avis a la tête sur les épaules et
est il préparé shoppach faire une grande
carrière qui fait des études aulas est
allé d'un haut niveau
donc voilà si on ne peut que cat
admiratif face à ce jeune homme qui à
plus de 22 ans donc il a tout il a plus
de vaslui quoi il aurait pu participer
aux jo de tokyo cet été son cheval était
qualifié mais son cheval s'est blessé du
coup il n'ira pas à tokyo cet été mais
il ira sûrement aux jo de 2024 bien sûr
s'il se qualifie mais il devrait se
qualifier normalement il va pas vous
prenez un bassin et 6
non non malheureusement là il attend
encore un peu avant de découvrir ces
jeux olympiques alors on passe
maintenant on va passer maintenant notre
yaggeuse rien j'ai juste un peu dommage
parce que c'est vrai que je pense que
entre l'ambiance olympique même si elle
va être un petit peu tronqué cette année
l'expérience d'un d'un d'une compétition
olympique est là elle a de toute façon
toujours une grosse différence par
rapport à une compétition à championnats
du monde où une grosse compétition
internationale il ya des il ya souvent
des règlements ou des particularités sur
les concours dans des différends sur le
sur le concours olympique donc c'est
dommage moi je pense de parcours ne pas
avoir plus de participer cette année
maintenant voilà il a ont quand même
trois années pour pour acquérir de
l'expérience supplémentaire
et bien que les laissons le faire et il
est très jeune pour un cavalier 1 22 ans
seulement
je voulais juste ajouter quelque chose
que toutes les choses on va dire
intéressantes ont été dites à mon sens
aussi ça lui permet de sortir de sa zone
de confort des installations qui
connaissait très bien la boissière école
et à trois ans aussi des jo de se
remettre aussi un petit peu en question
de venir dans ces installations qui sont
vraiment au top pour préparer ce genre
de compétition les jo qui se dérouleront
en plus dans le parc du château de
versailles pour l'épreuve d'équitation
je pense que c'est aussi intéressant de
pouvoir se remettre en question et de
sortir de sa zone de confort il quitte
un petit peu son cocon familial qu'il
avait à la base du cou à côté de
rambouillet on va passer maintenant
notre page débats
on va passer à l'envolée est de grégory
surtout notre dessert dans ceux ci en
parler sport de quoi allez vous nous
parlez grigori ça on parlait des jeux
olympiques vais vous parler des jeux
olympiques qui arrive cet été à tokyo il
était prévu l'année dernière reportée en
raison du contexte sanitaire c'est du 23
juillet au 8 août et on ne va pas bouder
notre plaisir nickel on pourrait être
derrière de nombreuses athlètes
yvelinois ou qui s'entraînent dans les
yvelines on aura beaucoup de motifs
d'être devant notre télévision cet été à
coire et d'être fier à commencer par
maiva hamadouche on en dise un mot tout
à l'heure si titre de championne du
monde en boxe professionnelle les pros
qui pour la première fois accès logis au
à 31 ans elle bnn au le poison comme on
la surnomme sera la seule boxeur
tricolore en lice dans le tableau
féminin et ce dans la catégorie des
moins de 60 kg elle a remis les gants le
15 mai après deux opérations lourdes au
bras la même failli à perdre son bras et
pourtant la pensionnaire du boxing club
est en cours à saint quentin en yvelines
a validé son ticket lors du tournoi de
qualification aux jeux olympiques début
juin
cela montre sa grande force de caractère
et reporte porte drapeaux seraient même
pour elle la cerise sur le gâteau et
guillaume chaîne lui sera revanchard le
judoka a manqué d'un rien la sélection
pour rio en 2016 à à 34 ans le licencié
du cos de sartrouville semble être
arrivé à maturité numéro un dans sa
catégorie celle des moins de 73 kg il a
été préservé lors des tout récents
mondiaux début juin et guillaume chaîne
arrivera en grande forme pour le tournoi
revanchard aussi de ces dernières contre
performances élimination dès le premier
combat au championnat d'europe
tout comme lors du dernier grand slam à
kazan mais une cinquième place plus tôt
dans la saison au grand slam en
ouzbékistan on n'oublie pas bien sûr que
l'illinois a été double vice-champion du
monde en 2018 et 2019 elle dévoile son
objectif
un podium olympique la rameuse claire
bové sera également de la partie à rio
nous l'avons croisé lors d'un
entraînement à l'association sportive
mantaise son club
grâce à son athlète de 23 ans déjà
cadres de la sélection l'aviron français
a effectivement de belles chances de
briller au japon elle les derniers
résultats sont en plus au rendez vous 3
en deux de couple poids légers aux
régates de lucerne avec laura tarantola
bronze
skiff poids légers aux derniers
championnats d'europe je crois que c'est
une épreuve que vous appréciez le skiff
poids léger il semble michael c'était en
italie ces championnats d'europe
victoire en double poids légers en coupe
du monde à zagreb
la dynamique est donc au rendez vous
pour cette surdouée du sport qui aurait
pu même être triathlète de haut niveau
justement en triathlon les yvelines sont
aussi sur le devant de la scène à
grégory comment ne pas parler du à
triathlon nickel sans doute l'une des
principales chances de médailles
françaises aux jeux olympiques et trois
triathlètes du club de poissy figurent
parmi les tricolores cassandre beaugrand
30e à rio il ya cinq ans et dorian
coninx 36e pour sa part aux jo-2016 et
léonie perriot 26 ans qui disputera ses
premiers jeux olympiques
tous peuvent performer individuellement
mais c'est surtout dans le relais mixte
par équipes que l'équipe de france est
attendue elle qui glace elle qui glane
tous les titres mondiaux de ces
dernières saisons
l'objectif affiché une médaille d'or
dans ses tripes dans cette épreuve
je vois sourire ihany jarrier ya
également du cyclisme le cyclisme qui
pourrait briller sur ces jeux olympiques
d'abord la sélection piste très jeune
21,8 en saas et la moyenne d'âge de
l'équipe de france de cyclisme sur piste
pour ces jo c'est dire
mais ce n'est pas un problème at-il de
gros ryan et là sébastien ligier et
florian gringo ont tous brillé sur la
scène internationale dans les catégories
et juniors
aligné sur le keirin on commence par
ryan hellal 22 ans la vitesse
individuelle aussi et la vitesse par
équipes il a été champion d'europe de la
vitesse junior en 2017 il a même fait le
triplé en espoirs l'année suivante
vitesse par équipes vitesse individuelle
etc erin lui aussi est inscrit dans les
trois épreuves sébastien viger a
également à seulement 24 ans est déjà le
plus expérimenté de cette sélection en
2017 il était sacré champion d'europe de
la vitesse par équipes et aussi en
individuel enfin florian gringo
complètent cette équipe de france
masculine
il n'a que 20 ans mais le talent est là
champion du monde de la vitesse par
équipes juniors en 2018 la même année il
relie il il a réussi un doublé 1 kerry
n'est vitesse par équipes en championnat
d'europe juniors et que dire de mathilde
gros championne d'europe du keirin en
2018 et 2019
elle aussi est attendu sur la vitesse
individuelle
c'est une épreuve pour laquelle elle
avait glané une médaille de bronze au
championnat du monde
en 2019 alors tous ne sont pas yvelinois
bien sûr mais s'entraîne bien sûr dans
les yvelines dans ce vélodrome national
de saint quentin en yvelines où est
également installée le siège de la
fédération française de cyclisme
alors tout comme l'équipe de france de
bmx tout comme l'équipe de france de bmx
un autre a grand espoir des médailles
françaises on va dire l'entraîneur
l'entraîneur julien sastre par le même
de quinte flush royale pour ces cinq
athlètes sélectionnés
axel etienne manon valentino joris
daudet silva andré et romain mahieu le
palmarès est garni elle est bleue du bmx
sont l'une des meilleures nations la
preuve en est ils ont terminé premiers à
l'issue des qualifications olympiques
bref c'est un bon cru michael pour ces
jo 2020 2021 il se déroulant cette année
2021 j'en suis persuadé les yvelinois
vont faire briller la france à tokyo cet
été alors je sais que je suis mauvais en
pronostics attention je sais que mes
camarades vont vous rigolez là dessus
mais la qualité et les espoirs sont là
aux athlètes maintenant de nous faire
rêver
attention à grégorini a prédit également
une victoire de la france à l'euro aussi
en début de compétition on fait
attention à vos pronostics
donc combien de médailles vous avez vous
avez un pronostic ou pas en termes de
médailles
grégory au moins aller là je lisais
médaille d'or au moins pour les
triathlètes c'est l'objectif affiché est
on va on va partir sur un objectif de 5
6 médailles
est ce que vous êtes d'accord et grégory
oui ou non cinq six médailles aux jo
est-ce que les y vivent ont porté cette
délégation française
oui pour vous 4 du cookie être en visio
yens dujarrier jamais ce qu'on sait plus
souvent les médailles moi je suis ultra
chauvin donc de toutes façons et bien
sûr que je souhaite voir ce rédacteur
par les yvelinois et alors si si ce sont
des en plus des gens qui s'entraînent
qui sont originaires des yvelines bien
sûr que ce sera ce sera ce sera
formidable
on pourra les on pourra aller les
côtoyer des rencontres et quand ils
seront en tenue avec avec les médailles
autour du cou
voilà bien sûr que moi
principal est mon principal souhait
c'est de voir l'équipe de france de
vitesse de cyclisme sur piste de
remporter une médaille ça c'est vraiment
un souhait
mathilde elle a largement la halle et
les capacités d'être d'être sur le
podium entérine les trois garçons voilà
je vois bien une pareille un podium sur
sur la vitesse par équipes il y avait il
ya des monstres de toute façon dans
toutes ces disciplines c'est vrai que le
triathlon bah oui bien sûr que là la
france fait partie fait et grandissime
favori sur sur l'épreuve de relais mixte
ça va être léger au qui vont être à
suivre
je suis content d'être à la maison au
mois d'août moi je vais partir en
vacances au mois de juillet je vais
pouvoir passer un peu de temps et avec
le décalage horaire bien profité
profitez au maximum de 2 des
retransmissions et de ce sport qui est
du sport en général qui va pouvoir être
visible et c'est un grand plaisir de
pouvoir voir cette fait genre combien de
médailles du coup pour ces jeux
olympiques pour la délégation yvelinoise
française évinoise bien sûr le seriez
non elle se lit assez que haut niveau au
niveau du cyclisme sur le bmx ou sur
piste
là je pense qu'on a quand même beaucoup
de possibilités de médailles parce que
c'est celle des sportifs de qualité
ensuite après je connais un petit peu
moins bon mais attend monaco va ma
douche vous la connaissez peut-être
peut-être oui c'est sûr qu'elle fera une
taille je suis certaine je suis certain
elle fera un podium en gardant les les
vidéos ou bien sûr il faut voir les
vidéos mais après le nombre c'est
tellement le principal aussi c'est quand
avoir enlevé d'ailleurs française règle
générale c'est des jeux olympiques qui
soit yvelinois ou ou de la creuse
wajih ben oui mais la française qu'est
ce que vous en pensez manila je pense
que oui on va pouvoir gagner des
médailles des sports je confirme que je
joins qu'il ya discipline discipline
qu'elle voulait chez les français on a
des joueurs de qualité
pierre chevallier un seul demande que je
le prendrais pour tester la capacité de
ses emplettes à réagir au décalage d'un
an commandes sont préparées comme ils
ont gardé les commandes vont garder la
charge d'entraînement entre 2020 et 2021
tous contraints et forcés de pouvoir
remporter un deuxième élément qui est le
socle il devrait y avoir beaucoup moins
publique internationale que près du
cefrio et donc c'est plutôt les athlètes
japonais qui jour moi qui joueront
évidemment à dénicher un questionnement
sur la sur les hached et des sportifs de
haut niveau
théoriquement ça ne sonne rempart de
conques
mais il y en a je pense qu'ils auront
qui ont assumé assumer ce décalage d'un
an mieux que les autres notamment dont
on a souvent parmi qui sont plutôt en
train et qu'il veut quand même un atout
la chance de la chance de participer à
des jeux favoris vous restez sur vos 5 6
médailles on est d'accord mais c'est
vrai que le paramètre du public et le
fait aussi d'avoir décalé c'est vieillot
sas à prendre en compte donc on sera
attentifs bien sûr à cela on sera
attentif et on souhaite bon courage à
nos asie vinoy qui partiront à tokyo à
cet été on fera des reportages à la
rentrée on tentera d'avoir des réactions
sur les as possible médaille et même en
cas d'échec on essaie quand même de les
avoir on ne prend pas que les victoires
on prend également les défaites ça fait
partie du sport c'était des fêtes que se
construisent les meilleurs victoire
exactement et 2024 et
fond de la ligne droite on dira alors on
va maintenant parler de l'eco trail de
paris on ne parlera malheureusement pas
de l'académie de rugby qui ouvrira en
septembre à plaisir on en parlera dans
une prochaine émission à la rentrée du
coup on va parler de l'eco trail de
course à pied malgré de nombreuses
annulations à cause de la crise
sanitaire l'eco trail de paris devrait à
bien à se dérouler le 3 juillet avec
plusieurs courses au départ des yvelines
le seul gros changement devrait
concerner le 80 km au départ de lille
doit their de saint-quentin divine la
course mythique ne se terminera pas au
premier étage de la tour eiffel car la
dame de fer n'accueillera pas de pluie
avant le 16 juillet l'arrivée se fera
finalement devant le pont d'iéna au pied
de la tour eiffel l'eau rendez vous
devrait tout de même attiré plusieurs
milliers de participants la question sur
ce thème
est ce que cette non arrivée à la tour
eiffel va gâcher cette course
oui ou non vous était oui pour vous il
ya du jarrier ont fait un petit duel
entre a non non pierre chevallier alors
vous êtes un habitué où je suis habitué
des courses devions d'être ont bien
évidemment j'ai le physique pour ça non
je pense que l'essentiel et l'essentiel
de la course se joue ce jeu vous plaît
avant certes un côté un petit peu quand
on est un petit peu le show de l'arrivée
la tour pour avoir non pas couru cet
événement mais d'avoir suivi des potes
c'est en plus à une arrivée qui ait pas
d'autres mots qui achève de pouvoir
montrer le poids de devoir monter les
marches de la tour eiffel au delà du
côté du côté un petit cochon c'est ça
sort un petit peu des congés des cours
de près une traditionnelle comme c'était
paris de condamner c'est arrivé
tél c'est un dessin de ses biens pour le
côté comique de la course mais ça ne
s'annonce en ajoutant que deux parties
sont contraints côté peut-être un petit
peu plus compliqué de
aux salines et de terminer sur cette
france marc mais essentielle de l'accord
ses pensées dans les banlieues mois et
ont écopé dans les pvd heavy notamment
bon pas de changement majeur à lachute
portion d'un engouement très variés
qu'est ce que vous en pensez
vous avez dit oui la course est gâchée
finalement c'est non non non non et non
je suis à la course n'est pas du tout
gâcher je vais prendre simplement
l'exemple de beaucoup mais mes amis sur
les réseaux sociaux qui depuis quelques
semaines très brèves sont très très
content de pouvoir remettre des dossards
et de pouvoir refaire à nouveau des
compétitions et je pense que la course
aurait pu rester simplement dans les
yvelines de toute façon les compétiteurs
aurait les participants auraient été
contents de pouvoir de pouvoir y
participer
oui en effet 2021 ce sera l'année sur la
montée de la tour eiffel y reviendrons
pour pouvoir pour pouvoir gravir soit à
nouveau pour ceux qui participent tous
les ans soit pour ceux qui auront pas eu
la chance de pouvoir la halle à grimper
mais mais je pense qu'aujourd'hui tout
le monde se satisfait de pouvoir à
nouveau s'aligner sur des surveillances
sur des lignes de départ et remettre des
dossards pour pour pouvoir reprendre
goût à la vie tout simplement
donc donc pour moi aujourd'hui sur
chaleix ce type d'événement qui commença
à refleurir
eh bien ça veut simplement dire que oui
on a peut-être gagné 7,7 guerre contre
contre la copie manila vous êtes
d'accord avec rémi charrier
il faut recourir quoi qu'il arrive peu
importe le finale à la tour eiffel avec
ses paillettes
je ne sais pas si c'était la première
fois qu'ils mettent ça
c'est à la première retrait ils font ça
tous les ans je veux dire sera la finale
à laquelle les envies non je pense que
c'est pas si grave que ça qu'on soit pas
une fois tour eiffel puisque le pôle
principal effet sur le circuit on va
c'est le principe assez prendre plaisir
courir on a déjà fait des kilomètres en
qu'il faut après cela tôles épaisses on
a juste simplement une expérience en
plus pour marquer le coup et justement
c'est vrai que ça t'a csu côté
historique de la fin en fait elle a tout
fait mais l'effet fond qu'il faut
l'accepter explique c'est pour la photo
avant tout on l'a compris grégory mais
je trouve que vous avez choisi une bonne
thématiques pour pour refermer cette
saison qui est c'est une thématique un
peu à l'image et c'est un peu l'histoire
de votre saison
vaut-il mieux maintenir ou vaut-il mieux
annuler vaut-il mieux s'adapter
eh bien j'ai envie de vous dire il
fallait s'adapter un pur pour cette
course pour maintenir et bien cette
pratique du sport il ya une dizaine très
bien à la volonté de ses coureurs de
remettre ce dossard et de pouvoir rpt
participer à ce genre de compétition
donc j'ai envie de vous dire c'est pas
grave y'a pas d'arriver à la tour eiffel
cette année il ya quand même une arrivée
devant la tour eiffel dont il y aura
toujours ce symbole de la tour eiffel
devant la tour eiffel le gros de la
course c'est avant la tour eiffel et ça
aussi
pierre le disait très bien mais je
trouve que c'est une bonne thématiques
pour clôturer cette saison c'est
l'histoire de notre saison
le sport doit continuer doit s'adapter
et pour retrouver une pratique normale
on commence à retrouver une pratique
normale mais il faut s'adapter en
attendant et on l'a vu on s'adapte on
est en visio vous êtes en plateau on a
essayé toute l'année a en tout cas de
vous proposer le meilleur de ce sport
yvelinois dans ce talk y ait forcément
ce n'était pas simple tous les jours on
a dû se creuser la tête mais bon on
l'attend et et on a je pense plutôt bien
réussi genre qu'est ce que qu'est ce que
vous en pensez vous vous a pas entendu
sur la question ce que je voulais dire
juste pour ajouter sa salle avec un
petit côté finale sportif très très rude
à kiki quand même oui si c'est un fake
nick cannon il faut se les farcir
quarantaine d'années qui trahi les
escaliers d'après celle iconique
iconique je veux bien mais sportive aura
quand même il y avait ce petit ce type
cerise sur le gâteau mais bon le jeu
rejoint yann lorsqu'il y on est
tellement les gens sont tellement
contents doivent être un dossard de
faire du sport vive le sport et que ce
soit sous n'importe quelle forme je
serai encore à plus de finisher sur
cette édition
parce que je pense que quand on est en
bas de la tour eiffel quand on est
arrivé en bas de la tour eiffel va de
toute façon quel que soit l'état de
fatigue dans lequel on est on va réussir
à gravir à gravir jusqu'aux premières
premier étage là c'est le mental qui est
c'est le mental qui prend et quand on
est sportif voilà donc ça changera pas
grand chose au résultat simplement voilà
ils auront participé à una une édition
qui restera et certainement unique et
j'espère qu'il restera unique ça sera le
mot de la fin sur cette thématique le
mot de la fin sur sur cette saison à si
on parlait sport dans ce format là il y
aura également une émission spéciale
sion par les sports au golf national de
saint quentin en yvelines pour parler
des jo-2000 24 avec d'autres acteurs
mais en tout cas c'est fini pour vous
pour cette saison merci beaucoup c'est
déjà la fin de cette émission va
terminer comme d'habitude par une
citation
aujourd'hui je vous propose une citation
du boxeur mohammed ali la légende
n'abandonne pas en dur maintenant et vit
le restant de sa vie en tant que
champions je vous laisse méditer sur
cette phrase à bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]